I started about three years ago I went
on my own Med every mistake going my
wife all booked me onto your pound event
course and then when I went it was just
like bang like the moment I came home
and I were like we're doing everything
wrong What's the total value of the
whole portfolio that you've got now be a
minimum of 1.3 million you can either
invest in your education or you pay for
your mistakes that's it with property is
if you do it right it's very passive 275
we paid for it we've got a 60 Grand
refurb on it and the commercial
refinance on it we're looking at 460. I
feel like the property game is like I'm
in a corridor and there's doors
everywhere you've got to break through
all that Dome and you come to another
door and then I joined Academy and I
feel like you are there just kick it off
though and then I just walked through it
I'm like oh that was easy
[Music]
James congratulations on your huge
success in property you've been buying
all kinds of big properties in your
hometown why don't you just talk a
little bit about how you got into
property and what you've been doing
thank you so I started about three years
ago in total uh went on my own obviously
like everybody does
um made every mistake going
um I bought a property flipped it into
an HMR spent way too much money on it
made it really nice big issue with
Council on that one because uh Allen
hardware straight away they told me that
I didn't have to get tenants in it
before Article 4 came in I just had to
finish it which I did so then we
tenanted it all going well then when I
come to refinance it after I'd come to
your pound event and then thought I'm
gonna win it why am I paying a repayment
mortgage let's get it refinanced pull
some money back on it then when I did
that they wanted a certificate a lawful
development and then the council
declined it
um because the rasts didn't start until
after article four did you lose money no
I didn't lose money
um but I'd I'd I couldn't keep renting
it as an HMR like we'd planned so we had
to drop it down to two tenants and then
I did a bit of digging and found a
loophole that I could then rent it out
to an assisted living company because
that falls under category 3B and we'll
go into that in detail later yeah for
sure which is which is great when we met
was that your only property that was my
only property yeah which had been a
little bit of a disaster yeah just at
least yeah yeah I mean you often hear me
say you can either invest in your
education or you pay for your mistakes
exactly yeah and we're paid for those
mistakes yeah
um and then I swore I were never gonna
make a mistake like that again and then
I come across year one YouTube and I'm
like what's this every time I typed a
question in you'd pop up on a video and
I were like this guy knows his stuff and
then when my wife or booked me onto your
pound event course and right up to that
morning I weren't I weren't gonna go I
was like oh I don't need to go I don't
need to go and then when I went
it was just like bang like all moment
okay Mom and I were like we're doing
everything wrong
um completely changed everything that
we're doing and then I went back to the
uh brr to an essay course and then I
were hooked and I were like this is what
I need to do and then I realized I need
to invest in my education because you
don't know what you don't know and there
were questions I didn't even know I
needed to ask that were getting answered
for me
um so yeah then I joined Academy and it
just has gone I have to pinch this in
now because it's just gone absolutely
mental so you've got some big projects
on the go yeah what deals have you done
or what have you got going on or what's
happening now I've sold a couple of
deals I did a bit of deal selling
um
it took a lot of time because it's not
as easy as you think it's going to be to
start where but I got the training I got
set up sold a couple of deals made some
some quick fast cash but then I thought
I need to specialize in what I want to
do and that's BR to HMR so we started
um investing into that and I got a
little bit of cash to start with myself
which I'd built up over years because I
used to be a gas plumber and I got my
own business but I soon realized that
that weren't going to go far fast so
then when I did your um never use your
own money again chaining and then
realized that actually there's investors
out there those all Apple invest their
cash into deals when you're guaranteeing
them returns and money back and stuff
like that and then it's just blown up
and now we've got we've just completed
on his fifth one which is about to start
in about three week on refurb we're
halfway through a 10 bed at the moment
which is a nice project and we're
looking at the ROI again last night on
that and even fully managed with on
about a thousand and fifty percent ROI
thousands ridiculous it's nearly full
money art obviously so it's looking at
Dollar infinite we only leave about five
grand in it we paid 270 000 for that
yeah we're pumping 60 gram refurb into
it and then we'll be looking at on a
commercial refinance on conservative
figures we'll be leaving about five
grand in and that's turning over about
62 Grand a year in rent so that's a nice
one why do you think not everybody's
doing this why is everybody not buying
houses pushing the value up and
refinancing why do some people just save
up deposits and dump their money into
properties
knowledge Because unless you like say
you don't know what you don't know
um and the HMR strategy
maybe a bit biased here but I believe
that is one of the most difficult
strategies there's so much red tape when
you're starting out especially when
you're on your own there's so many rules
and regulations that you don't know
about and you will 100 get bitworm
so once you've done the training and you
you know what you're doing even now I
mean I'm on my fifth one and I'm still
learning stuff a bit of Tricks but you
know just to just to make it happen
quicker and easier and get better
returns
um every day is a school day I think the
fact that hmos are highly regulated to
me I think it's a really good thing
because if it was as easy as just buying
a house and then just renting the rooms
out yeah everybody would really do it
yeah but because it's highly regulated
and you need licensing there's article
four potential planning people think oh
I don't want to touch that with a barge
Bowl there's also big fines isn't there
yeah yeah you can do it wrong yeah 30
grand fine yeah yeah a bank yeah or you
can either go to prison yeah the swim
stuff is Criminal yeah which we got not
threatened way but when we when we um
applied for a certificate of lawful
development yeah e the planning didn't
tell us that we couldn't use it as an
HMR but they told us that weren't gain
as a certificate on it and he told us
that if we did get investigated we could
be fair oh
[Laughter]
I'm ready to go to prison yes
but yeah so that one a big learning
curve and to be honest when that
happened
it well I before I joined academy and
our teaching on edge are just thinking
I've done my property
um I'm gonna go back Plumbing because I
want to learning good money plumbing and
eating but I were working very very hard
for it and I knew they were going to
come a time in my life when I couldn't
do it anymore when my knees packed in
um or I wanted to retire and that money
would have just stopped dead unless I'd
have built a plumbing in eating business
up which I started to do a little bit
employing people but I soon realized
that that took more time up than it did
actually doing the work and I thought
it's very difficult to make that a
hands-off business one hour one with the
HMR strategy is eventually to be able to
hand them over to management companies
and they're pretty much passive income
um so I can literally
have time off go on holiday take kids
away see me wife just sit at home if I
want and I mean I'll probably never do
that but I'd like the opportunity to be
able to do that
um and for me that was that's it with
property is it's
if you do it right it's very passive
just takes a lot of work to start with
yeah and you need people in your corner
you can't do it alone not whether we are
and I remember you're saying to me at
one at events you said you were going to
be successful in property whether you
joined Academy or not which I agree with
but after joining Academy it's just sped
everything up 10 times right and
position I'm in now I think would have
taken me while I was 56 in another 20 25
years to get to
and I've done it in eight months wow
that's why I have to pinch me saying
because I'm like yeah is this happening
I remember saying that to you because I
remember saying look you will be
successful regardless yeah but yeah it's
okay so do you want to go on your own
yeah or do you want to be part of a
community where you've got mentors
you've got training because that will be
a lot more fun definitely and it will be
awesome and it is fun yeah it is fun as
well as it's been all the knowledge and
the help that you get it's it's fun uh
amount of people that I've met or alike
a lot and our class as friends now that
you would never meet you can go to a
networking event and meet some people or
you might think oh they're all right you
don't really get to know them as such
you might swap contact details you might
have some emails back and forth but in
the academy you're thrown in a mix
together and you're with them people a
lot and you get to know people on a real
personal level and I've met some really
really good people aren't they how many
units do you own now then we're just
coming up to 29. wow that's amazing and
we're looking at buying another tool
this year are you getting commercial
valuations or are you getting we're
doing it yeah we've got one which is
just about to complete the refurb this
week actually
um which is a six bed so we're going to
try on a commercial refinance on that
obviously six beds can be a little bit
in a gray area but it's full unsweeted
it's other four floors it'd be quite
difficult to put it back to a
residential so we're confident on that
to get a commercial or at very least a
good hybrid valuation yes and then it's
10 bed we nailed on to get a commercial
on that one that cannot go back to a
residential yeah the 10 bed what are the
figures as to how much did you buy it
for we bought it for 270 and what was it
was it just a house it was very it was a
seven month purchase this one it was it
were very sketchy so originally it was a
house then it got changed to a HMR then
they got a classy planning on it to
change it to officers which it never
actually got changed They carried on
using it as an HMR which technically
were illegal because it were down as
officers they run that then for 15 years
and then three years ago they didn't
really want license on it and it was sat
empty so it was sat empty on a Class E
classification so I know and the
property is stunning it's such a nice
looking house but they sold off a big
part of the back Garden because at one
point it was a hostel so they split the
title and they built a um warden's house
so the back Garden is really tiny so it
can't go back to a residential so we had
a long battle with Council that's why it
took seven months to actually from offer
going in to get it keys because we
needed to make sure that we could do it
as a HMR because to split it up into
Flats studio apartments which would have
been as as backup plan we'd have just
about rock even on it we couldn't
possibly sell it as an house so we
needed to get we needed to get planning
on it and we were in an article 4 area
very anti-hmr it's also a conservation
area that street no one would touch that
with a barge bar an hour but because
your figures are so good on it like I
said it's 270 or 275 repaired for it
we've got a 60 grand
um refurb on it yeah and the commercial
refinance on it conservatively we're
looking at 460. so what would the profit
on that about 100 Grand yeah easy over
100 Grand profit yeah so I figures we
leave about 5 000 in the deal so you'll
refinance it then yeah talk me through
the process of buying a house refurbing
it and refinancing it so we generally
buy them at a lower value I.E when they
need a lot of work so we can add value
to it we purchased it till 70. we put a
60 gram Reverb into it so we're like 330
in so we'll then approach your lender
when when it's completed they'll send a
new guy out to Value it then we kind of
like sell it back to the lender as such
and they'll release us 75 percent of the
total value it'll pay off all that is
refurb money minus five grand
um and then a little leave 25 in deal on
a standard HMO or commercial mortgage
yeah and what do you think the profit
will be on that profit on that we're
looking about 35 Grand a year yeah about
50 yeah just just less we usually knock
about 40 off for bills and everything
because we do make them really well
insulated a good high efficiency eating
system I'm a gas plumber by trade so I
know what system it's that toilet
no charge as well yeah so I know what
systems to put in just to try and keep
bills down yeah and we've not been
single banded on it yet if that comes in
or not I don't know but as of now we're
lucky with it so yeah we we're looking
mid 30s profit on it I've joint ventured
on that one as well so you got someone
to put the money in yeah how much did
you put into that deal up to now zero at
all nothing nothing no so I'm I'm doing
all the work The Sweat Equity of it oh
wow and what I've done is I've got we've
got a contract drawn up between us that
the investor gets a minimum of 75 of his
money back on the refinance and I cover
him as well so if for any reason it fell
through on the gdv on the value if it
got down valued which is very unlikely
but if it did he's covered that he gets
a larger percentage 75 of the rent
income I'll manage it as well do any
repairs until he's it is 75 back right
and then we split it so it the investors
covered every which way yeah they can't
possibly lose out but looking at the
figures as I said he's his deal to get
full money back in less than eight
months and I think every joint venture I
mean there's always an element of risk
with any deal you do yeah yeah even
driving to work you could get it you
could have a car accident there's always
risk yeah but what you need to do is you
need to make sure every joint venture
there's equal risk and equal reward yeah
so not one person's taking all of the
risk you're spreading the risk yeah my
risk is obviously time yeah because I'm
putting a lot of time into this I mean
I'm working six seven days up in it up
until late at night or gym materials for
Builders organizing everything I'm
actually Hands-On the project as well
more or less every day so time wise I'm
I'm I would lose a lot the investor is
obviously cash so he he don't have to
come he don't have to do anything he's
just injected the cash and just waits
for his his return
how did you find the investor to put in
all the money the first Dow joined the
academy uh back in end of June I signed
up that day and that evening about four
or five hours after we had a Academy
dinner which my first Academy dinner
um and I went in
and now we're going to sit on a table
with a guy who had been chatting with
earlier that day and he sat down and
that what last see he took him that
table saw like oh it's fine I'll go
somewhere else so I looked about and I
just randomly went and sat next to a guy
which we sat chatting he wanted to
invest in hmrs it weren't too sure on
the strategy then
um because he was he were brand new he'd
signed up that day as well so I told him
what we'd been doing with us and I said
to him well you know if I get any good
deals at all I'll I'll throw me away if
you want so I said yeah and it were
during that time that our I then started
looking at this this property and found
it and then once I'd learned how to run
out figures and get me out of eye sheets
together
didn't matter which way I put it down it
just kept coming out as a fantastic deal
um and I just pitched it to him well he
pitch it to him I showed him it and they
were like yeah I'm in straight away and
then since then we've done another one
together as well so my name's got two
going at the moment
um and on gdvs with both of them we're
looking about six hundred thousand
What's the total worth or value of the
whole portfolio that you've got now the
thought the gdv yeah and the five
properties
um conservatively we're going to be a
minimum of 1.3 million
yeah I mean I come from a council estate
me so them candy numbers to me are just
surreal honestly like I I have to pinch
this in sometimes I can't I can't
believe we're in this situation but then
my wife's like yeah we're in this
situation because you've put so much
time and effort into it and then
obviously investment into Academy were
just literally the best thing I've ever
done
um because I would not be here now no
way I'd probably be doing property but I
might I got maybe another the wall and
I'd be struggling and you know I've been
knocking me out on wooden whereas now
it's just like it's like I feel like the
property game is like I'm in a corridor
and there's doors everywhere and you
come up to a door and you've got to get
through it you've got to break through
all that door and then you come to
another door and then I joined Academy
and I feel like you are there just
kicking door through yeah and then I
just walked through it I'm like oh that
was easy and then I walked out next one
and uh progress is just happening so
fast it's exciting talk to me a bit
about the area that you're in because
the rules are really strict yeah they've
even got Fuller before in there yeah how
the heck are you doing Buy refurbished
refinance to HMO in an area that's got a
complete article four that's really
strict anti-hmos oh yeah yeah I'm making
so much money what what tricks and tips
can you share
um it was very very difficult in my area
and I'm up north in South Yorkshire and
like you said the very anti-hmr so I I
had to just learn all the legalities
around it all to be able to Fight Fire
with Fire basically
um and a good strategy that we're doing
is we're buying run-down hmrs that are
already C4 classification right so we've
got grandfather rights on them we're
buying them at a lower value because the
run down we're refurbing them increasing
value and pulling his money back out
that's great so that that is a give me
an example of one of those though and
just to anyone that doesn't understand
C40 so it's just the class what the
classification of the property is yeah
so obviously a standard residential
property is C3 classification yeah and
you talked about e that's just business
yeah it's business officers things like
that yeah C4 hmm C4 is HMR so if it's
already C4 all we've got
historical ast's pre-article 4 which is
another saggy you have to go when you're
buying them
um then you've got grandfather rights to
be able to keep running it as an HMR but
there is an in-between classification as
well
um which we found out because of this
first one now we've got bit so heavily
we hit I did a lot of digging uh I got
help from Academy I got help from
solicitors we then finally nailed down
that there's a there's a classification
in between it all called c3b
which even in an article 4 area
we are allowed to legally go from C3 to
c3b under permitted development and c3b
is there's a there's a few different
examples but one is an assisted living
company can rent it off me so this HMR
that we are lumbered with that won't
give us a certificate on to be able to
refinance we are now handing that one
over to a assisted living company we're
going to kind of like do a corporate let
to our company they rent it off me for a
fixed amount completely hands off we can
then refinance it as a c3b
classification and we'll be able to pull
his money back out of it and that we can
do we app permission as long as it's
under six
and that falls under category c3b so
yeah we're looking forward now to moving
on that one and that might be a strategy
that we'll look at doing permanently
because we're building a relationship up
with this Assisted Living company yeah
so that means we can start buying them
in article 4 areas we can kit them out
as an HMO
and then we can hand them over to this
Assisted Living company and then we'll
talk about it on YouTube everyone will
do it and they'll change the rules again
exactly yeah but it's okay then we'll
find somewhere else and then we'll find
something else and we'll share that
YouTube exactly another thing I'd rather
share because I think coming from a
position of abundance so many property
investors and developers that do all
these little loopholes and these little
hacks and then they keep them to
themselves yeah they do yeah yeah yeah
and I think just bring everybody up with
you yeah because then it's easier to
grow if everybody around you is Rich
it's easier to get richer so yeah I've
been sharing that with a lot of Academy
members and they've been loving it and
they've been feeding back to me I had
four phone calls somewhere down here
actually about hmos and even you've been
so popular we're actually bringing you
down next week to just sit in a we're
going to lock you in a little Mentor box
so yeah but we do that at all the events
every program that we have we've got
like Mentor boxes where if anyone's
struggling they go out have some
one-on-one time of somebody's more
experience which I did when I were brand
new into Academy yeah well I've been
mentoring calls and meetings which were
I remember I remember the story about
your your bad tenant yeah the one that
we couldn't get rid on yeah talk about
that what happened uh so we bought a HMR
um race recently well quite a few months
ago now um which were a six bed and it
got four sitting tenants in it and the
previous landlorded section 21 demol so
they had to move out by a few days after
we completed which were a bit bit risky
and three other guys moved out straight
away and one of the guys dug his heels
in and he said he weren't going anywhere
so we were like oh God so we got a six
bed HMR Builders were booked in to come
in on the Monday and the Monday morning
when we got there he would not leave
anyone meant to have left like a few
days before and so we had to cancel
Builders it just turned into a right
Saga and obviously you know what
Builders are like if you're upset them
then that's it oh they just burnt in it
so we then integrated Plan B and we
looked at if we could do the refurb
around him while he was still in think
on his pay no renty they'd not paying
rent for three months to the previous
landlord and the council were advising
him just to sit tight and not move not
get his key back why would they advise
him to do that because he would have a
problem and not theirs and then the
older as soon as he moved out if he got
nowhere to go which obviously we're
going to find it difficult because it
got three months rent arrears swinging
around his neck so they just wanted him
to stay there basically so we looked at
if we could refurb it around him but it
just weren't logistically possible
because we had to change eating system
and plumbing system we were adding on
Suites and stuff like that
Yeah well yeah but legally we've still
got to provide him yeah you know Heating
and hot water and that's just going
turnt water off and say sorry it's not
going to be on for three there is
legislation yeah
and it is someone's home as annoying as
it is yeah so what did you do what what
happened at that point where you've got
this terrible annoying tenant not paying
any rent potentially costing you
thousands of pounds yeah so our book to
Mentor I didn't call
um we're so yeah and she I mean me being
a Barnsley man just wanted to go in and
evict him you know to settles and she
were like you cannot do all that
um so she says right this is what you
need to do and basically to cut
alongside a shot she got me to write up
a very simple
termination a deed for him to sign and
we told him he owed three months rent
which he didn't really Auto was anywhere
he odd to previous he only orders about
two or three weeks rent which he'd not
paid so we said to him you can live here
for another two week rent free
and will will not chase you on the rent
areas if you agree to move out by said
date so we went another chat with him
genuinely tried to help him out this guy
he agreed to sign this termination
indeed
and then come the day we're meant to
move out he he'd not gone
so legally we could have got police in
because we were there as a as a squatter
technically we waited for him to leave
the property and we change the locks and
I got all this stuff backed up we
thought it all first bagged all his
stuff up put it in a van and when he'd
gone he went up to council to go and see
if they could help him out he said he
won't we don't think he will but
whatever we we then called him and said
where do you want your stuff dropping
off
and he absolutely ate Rolf and he come
down he brought the council William so
we showed him his termination a deed and
they literally just went
where are you going to put his stuff
So I says our story is still free of
charge I've got a heated garage I says
I'll put it in there it can stop as long
as he wants and until he gets his sin
sorted out so yeah we got ridden him but
I would not have known that unless I've
booked a mentoring call and spoke to sue
um and she just made it so much easier
because alternative it had been take him
to court Section 8
six months and him not paying rent
Builders are stalled everything had to
just you know it should have gone Airway
yeah it shows the power of having
mentors around you being on the academy
being able to book mentoring Goods
because you never know do you when you
might just suddenly need to you might
not need a mentoring call for a few
weeks then you suddenly need exactly
yeah yeah it's still not I bought
something because everybody's really
good at certain things yeah no I don't
think anybody knows everything yeah you
need people around you because there's
so many strategies and so many different
Avenues yeah that you need a big team
around you yeah if you want to listen to
those accountants yeah experts in sales
yeah sometimes people just say I've got
a deal I'm struggling to sell it yeah
yeah because they don't know how to sell
yeah yeah you've got to have that
Network around you if you want to be
super successful yeah if you want to do
all right in property and get to three
grand a month coming in you can
eventually do it on your own over time
and it's going to take you a long time
but if you want to upscale and turn it
into a business and make it completely
answer off you've got to have a good
structure around you to to help well I'm
absolutely over the moon at your success
and I'm really grateful that you know
you're giving back even coming on
Wednesdays on a Wednesday yeah the
golden nuggets from this one have been
huge yeah so thanks so much what will be
your final words of wisdom or words of
advice to someone that's wanting to get
started into property there's I could
say so much
um but the the key is to get the
knowledge and get the get the people
around you that's gonna that's gonna
help lift you up because even in your
day-to-day life your parents and your
friends are not into property they can't
help you as much as they might want to
help you they can't help you with the
legalities and things like that you need
successful people around you to drag you
up quicker so yeah you need to get the
knowledge you need to just not be trying
to take it all on your own shoulders
like I would originally yeah because I'm
a bansley man and I thought you know
I'll do it myself and that does not work
you've got to have people helping you
which times thank you very much it's
been a pleasure
[Music]